rich will get the next talk
okay good afternoon everyone
it's great to be here I'll now be
talking about our business around the
clock which is joint work with Yves
who's also with us so let me start with
some general background I think in
recent years mechanism design in
particular market design has received
some increase that increased attention
from a behavioral perspective and that
has revealed that even strategy proof
mechanisms often do not work so well and
so two examples of that would be one
from the field high-stakes decision the
u.s. medical residency match where it's
not well documented that a lot of
medical students misrepresent their
preferences trying to strategize in a
strategy proof mechanisms where their
dominant strategies to truthfully report
your ranking another very different
example it's very old goes back to the
80s where Keiko Carson and Levin have
shown that the seal bit second price
auction where it's a dominant strategy
to true to bid your true valuation in a
private values context and they've shown
that the seal paid second price auction
leads to severe over bidding and that
also divides learning whereas the
theoretically equivalent ascending clock
auction they're people very quickly
figure out that it's best for them to
stay in up to the point where the clock
price reaches the evaluation and then
drop out so this is challenging to
theory because of all these mistakes
they could not be due to the kind of
well known difficulties that people came
here is the focused on that are due to
difficulties in mistakes due to
difficulties in strategic or equilibrium
reasoning because people have a dominant
strategy here so something else must be
going on and then a few years ago
Changu are proposed
and what more an answer to the question
what the issue is and also a fix so to
speak so a basic idea I would say is
that recognizing dominance is not so
easy because there can be a lot of
contingencies that you have to
distinguish as I requires some
contingent reasoning in terms of what
others might be doing and you need to go
through all of these contingency by
contingency to see that this one
strategy actually does better than
anything else you could do and probably
it's easy to get confused there
importantly so provides a formal
definition of when dominance should be
obvious from the extensive game form or
from mechanism you know in a way that it
relaxes the contingent reasoning
requirements for recognizing dominance
and based on serve this notion of
obvious dominance he proposes selection
criterion called obvious strategy proof
nests as of that whenever it applies we
sort of should use this criterion to
select those strategy proof mechanisms
where dominance is actually obvious to
people which would avoid any sorts of
mistakes and so that promises huge
welfare gains and moreover it also
provides his own lab evidence that this
actually has behavioral content and it
does what it's supposed to be so it
replicates this old finding on auctions
which supports the theory because the
CEO paid second price auction which is
here 2p is not obviously strategy proof
whereas the ascending clock auction is
obviously strategy proof I also there's
also another comparison that also
provides overwhelming support which is
on random serial dictatorship mechanisms
and we'll hear more about that tomorrow
as I saw on the program
it's exactly the same evidence this is a
high-powered replication of the eighties
study so what do we do in our paper more
detail is to come of course
so we revisit this Auctions evidence
with private known values and so first
we'll argue that this evidence is
subject to some potential confounds of
theoretical or business in terms of
design differences where these
conference may be of independent
interest for a designer designing
auctions or more generally mechanisms
then we saw provide an experiment that
quantifies these compounds that are
related to so how feedback is given also
relevant information and also isolate a
key requirement of theoretical or
business which is sort of two bit
dynamically and we do so by comparing
not just to P and AC but so if we add a
set of auction formats in between those
two to isolate and to zoom in on the
design differences and see the effects
of these differences on behavior what we
find this of that the significantly
superior performance of the ascending
clock auction is almost entirely due to
those count funds and we can discuss
what this means about the theory or in
what sense these are con funds and
finally we also add a structural
analysis of bidding behavior so as it
relates to actual material incentives
and that tries to look deeper into how
design actually affects behavior not
just how close you get to dominance but
also what kind of mistakes people make
okay so let's start with bringing
everybody on the same page at some
theoretical background I guess we all
know what dominance means it's just a
tone and strategy has the property that
no matter what others end up doing it's
always better than any alternative
strategy so once you've figured out your
dominant strategy is no need to spend
any thoughts or effort mental effort on
trying to
dick others behavior because no matter
what they do you'll do this strategy
proof nurse as a property of a mechanism
just means that mechanism implements
something in dominant strategies now
what's at the notion of obvious
dominance as a dominant strategy it's
obvious from an extensive game form if
as long as you've been following that
strategy it will always be the case that
if even if the worst happens and you
follow through on that strategy you
still do at least as well as with any
strategy that deviates there so even if
you get totally confused you don't
compare strategies case-by-case but even
if you're very confused well you will
never reach a point where you think oh
the deviation is profitable okay that's
kind of the idea in that sense it
relaxes that contingent reasoning an
obvious strategy proof nurse centrist
means implementation and obviously
dominant strategies for the particular
problem we're looking here you're
looking at here where there's a single
object that you want to allocate among a
number of people with private values
Changu also provides a characterization
basically shows that this requirement of
having dominance obvious to everyone
tells you that you should run an
ascending clock option all right now
let's just think about why the CEO paid
second price auction is not obviously
that strategy proof so there it's a
static auction everybody submits their
bid at the same time and then the person
with the highest bid gets the prize or
it means the object and paste the second
highest bid so there's just it's just
one decision I make and if I bid
truthfully the worst that can happen is
that I don't get the price now if I
think okay maybe I should bid I consider
a deviation to say bidding twice my
value the same goes if I did have my
value what's the best that could happen
under this deviation the best that could
happen is everybody else but zero I get
the object for free so that if I'm
totally confused I'm I think that's
that's a good idea so it's not obviously
dominant to bid my my value here
now how about the ascending clock
auction there in this and it's a dynamic
auction there's a public clock price it
starts very low and then slowly
increases and at any point you decide
whether to remain in the auction or sort
of irreversibly drop out now there it's
the dominant strategy as I said to stay
in until the clock price hits your value
and then drop out if you follow that
strategy the worst that can happen at
any point is well you also don't get the
object you'd never lose anything now
however if the price is below your value
you should stay in now what's a
deviation there a deviation would mean
you drop out what's the best case well
there's just one case you don't get the
object it's certainly not better okay
once the price goes beyond your
valuation the best that could happen if
you stay in if you deviate and stay in
is that also others stay in longer and
you don't win the auction because if you
win you actually lose okay so there by
here the staying in until your value is
actually an obviously dominant strategy
okay let's spend a few words on how to
test its theory what kind of predictions
it makes so the domain of the theory is
that of strategy proof mechanisms or
extensive game forms and so it divides
this space into those mechanisms where
dominance is obvious and those where
it's not now as a test you would compare
mechanisms want at it sort of solve the
same problem one where dominance is
obvious another way it's not obvious and
the prediction will be that when it's
obvious behavior is significantly more
in line with playing the dominant
strategy okay it's worthwhile pointing
out that it's sort of not a theory of
behavior within any given mechanism but
the prediction always concerns
comparisons across mechanisms so it's
not supposed to explain what kinds of
systematic mistakes people make the idea
is it captures something fundamental
about how people about strategic
cognition or you know cognition in a
game that avoids whatever mistakes
people would make otherwise
okay now some issues that we resolved
when we thought about this some some
issues came came to our minds which is
sort of it's a very complex and rich
domain it's many comparisons you could
run and in any comparisons there's
multiple aspects that vary
simultaneously there's always the
question what actually drives behavior
and how informative is any given
comparison so to take an example the CEO
paid second price auction your action
space you can make all of various bids
whereas in the it's the ascending clock
auction it's a dynamic format and you
always make binary decisions is it just
about making binary decisions is it just
about doing making dynamic decisions
it's hard to say
moreover typically you would run this
comparison over several rounds and
already after the first round what
people have experienced it's very
different okay so these are issues we
want to address with our with our
experiment
so we also run replicate so of the
comparison between the 2p and the AC
auction that I already explained this
the ascending clock auction as it's
basically always implemented in
experiments it also provides your
theoretically irrelevant information in
the following sense at all the clock
would always show how many people are
still competing with how many people are
still in the auction it's theoretically
relevant because you know what your
value is shouldn't matter but you know
practically you can think about why it
might actually matter and we'll we'll
see whether it does in any case we also
implement the so so what we call
deep-lined at the sending o'clock
auction where that information is absent
from the clock so bidders never know how
many others are still in the auction
what they do know is as long as the
auction is running somebody else is
still in the auction that's important
then we're also the other sort of
potential confound the one address is
that of feedback so here we run also to
additional auction formats that are sort
of hybrids between a clock auction and
the static auction in the following
sense bidding is exactly as in in in the
sealed bid format so it's static auction
people just submit bids after bid
submission however we run an ascending
clock auction today this auction is one
that people would just consume passively
they couldn't do anything during that
auction anymore but it would just sort
of resolve the bidding like an ascending
clock auction where the bids that people
have made act as sort of automatic exit
prices okay so this ensures that people
would see would always see the similar
feedback yeah so they would have the
same chance of learning from the clock
as if they actually acted in the clock
okay so we have two versions of this one
where this sort of passive ascending
clock auction also doesn't show how many
bidders are still in there and one where
it does show how many bidders are still
in there
so the idea is now to say okay in this
comparison of 2p and AC we'll probably
see that AC does much better people are
much closer to dominance and if we turn
that say there's a hot we say there's a
hundred percent we scale this to a
hundred percent of the difference and
then we want to know how big is the
contribution of just presenting the
clock after bid submission how much is
the contribution to the reduction in
mistakes that we get from dynamic
bidding which turns dominance obvious
theoretically and how much is due to
providing life dropout information and
here we also have the drop out
information it's though it's it's
different because it's not live you
cannot directly respond to this
information it's just part of your
feedback but okay so that's what we do
these to do are dynamic strictly
speaking dynamic auctions these three
are static auctions
and are all equivalent to 2p it's
exactly the same thing just what changes
is sort of the feedback dimension which
is around learning are you going to talk
about that as well yeah definitely story
is going to rely on learning exactly and
we'll also be able to see how to what
degree there the thought that youth so
whether this is through learning it's
just about faster learning or whether
it's something that happens immediately
as all these experiments we let people
play multiple rounds of those okay
and so aggregating over all those rounds
and I'll give you more details later
here's the decomposition so basically
this is a hundred percent so if we move
here and add up the numbers it's a
hundred percent actually we get roughly
forty percent reduction in mistakes or
deviations from dominance if we provide
this live dropout information which is
theoretically relevant also to our
business now of the remaining of sixty
percent almost 50% of the reduction is
due to their seeing the clock passively
if you then let them actively bid
dynamically on the clock it just adds of
another twelve percent so we could say
you get almost the benefits of this
obviously strategy proved mechanism just
by showing people the clock another view
of this where you just look at the
initial behavior I'm assuming this is
well it will come so this as I said this
is the big aggregated result now let's
look into a detail a bit more okay where
these numbers come from that we get from
the clock option is 49 plus 12 plus 39
yes sir so the benefit this is the
details will come but it's sort of we
measure absolute deviations from the
dominant strategy and we aggregate over
all the rounds that we let them do this
and as I've measured a hundred percent
and we just see how much of that is a do
we get through with mistakes reduced
here compared to here where we normalize
this to a hundred percent one hundred
percent difference between 2p and AC
yeah certainly this one does better than
all the others by the way so
surprisingly even when the drop out
information is just part of the passive
feedback that people wrote the feedback
that people get it's actually a 25 worth
25 percent on that scale in terms of
we'll come to that okay just what did we
do we basically replicated sheng gu's
experiment using so what's available
publicly online with minimal adaptations
for the new treatments they're very
similar to the original benchmark wants
to do because you can talk to Eve about
that we had subjects bid for money
prizes worth up to 130 euros in groups
of four we use affiliated private values
just like Xingu did we're sort of
there's one draw that's for the group
and then there's another draw that's
individual and each person's private
value is the sum of these so they don't
know other people's values but with
affiliated with private values they're
so that the idea is not very far away
from their own so a group value was the
draw uniform draw from the range 10 to
110 euros these private adjustments were
drawn from 0 to 20 euros uniform okay
and we actually use the same sets of
values value drawers as Chang who used
and
we had 20 auctions per session
and all of those counted as very high
stakes and if somehow they they could
have bankrupted us very quickly the
first block of ten auctions was the
standard auctions yeah we wanted to do
exactly oh yes although there's another
treatment at the rsd that is much higher
states okay so the first of the first
block of ten rounds was standard
auctions just like I explained them and
then exactly what I explained earlier
the rules of the game now the question
is more what's the other auctions yeah
exactly
the indeed the first ten for each format
are exactly as I explained now the
second block are some little perturbed
versions of those where in order to win
you had to outbid the second highest
bidder by an unknown random amount X
drawn from 0 to 3 euros beforehand
unknown to the players they only knew
there would be this random amount it
doesn't change anything you should still
drop out at your value and so on but it
makes things a bit more obscure and the
idea of that was that you know maybe
there are differences across formats and
how familiar people are with them and
that way you would sort of level the
playing field but it's important to note
that in all cases these auctions were
run on people with 10 rounds of
experience with the standard version
now the average payment in our case was
24 euros sessions lasted between 75 and
90 minutes we had a rough roughly around
70 subjects per treatment okay so here
first picture we here we just look at
the benchmark treatments 2p and AC to
peen orange AC in black here we have the
left column it's the standard auctions
right column is the second block of ten
rounds the actual X auctions and here we
have the rounds okay ten rounds second
ten rounds on the top we have our data
for them we have Sheng boost data and
what we measure here is the mean
absolute deviation of bids from values
where we only use non winning bids
because we don't have winning bids in
the dynamic format basically all this
ones is supposed to tell you is that the
replication was successful yeah patterns
look very similar quite robust so let's
look at our data what's there to see
well right from the beginning AC yeah
yeah exactly
you're either always in to P or always
in AC or always in to Parker are we here
is only these two treatments the other
three they're to come
so right from the beginning a/c does
quite better than to pee people are much
closer to the truthful bidding and what
you see is or after just one round of AC
people have figured out what's there to
figure out for them and already after
the second auctions basically quite flat
exactly this is our data this is with
zangoose data on these two treatments so
now this so now since the replication
was successful we focused on our data
yeah right so so they're very quickly
learned are already after to say in the
second round they've learnt it whereas
in the Silpat format they do quite a
little bit worse in the very first round
learning takes place but it's very slow
just in a very less two rounds maybe
they get close to to having learned as
much as in AC they've already learned a
third after a single round
that was a bad design decision on my
part I should probably have swapped out
a Saxon I didn't think of it at the time
for budgetary reasons we
yeah
okay so then where do the new what do
the new treatments look like here's
those three new ones that we added so in
green it's this blind at the sending
o'clock auction in red it's this - Park
auction where it is an ascending clock
auction with drop out information after
pit submission and there's in blue it's
- Part B and what we see is well in the
first two rounds the ascending clock
auction does somewhat better but after
from round three onwards they're very
similar the only thing maybe there's a
slight advantage for Tupac here in red
in the standard auctions but in the X
auctions they're all very similar park
is the one where so it's like the 2p
auction
except that after bid submission they
watch an ascending clock auction with
their pizzas automatic exit prices what
what is this how does this relate to the
benchmark treatments it's right in the
middle all right so learning is not as
fast as in AC it's a bit slower for all
these three I bet towards the end of the
standard options there if they're very
similar and then the X options they're
indistinguishable basically okay so
apparently yeah exactly so the first
round death there that's the idea
exactly so initially these are sending
clock auctions do significantly better
in the first round learning takes place
very quickly in AC but not in this other
format it also did they learn quite a
lot but then they stay above the AC
auction and if you compare the other
ones where they also see a clock but
just as sort of as part of their
feedback it's basically the same
what do you mean it's not significant
okay so the additional ones yeah exactly
that's right let's look at so this so
far this is we just look at absolute
deviations from dominance we don't look
at what actually underlies those
deviations what kind of mistakes do
people make and that's sort of is the
next step but the point is people
initially they do better and under the
obvious dominance very quickly if they
see a clock once or twice they do as
well unless they actually also get this
live drop out the information now we
want to understand better what's
actually going on before let me
summarize so basically if we compare a
CB and to Part B except for the very
first two rounds you obtain the benefits
of of obvious just by through that
feedback through the clock initial
behavior versus learning well we don't
see an instructions effect yeah so to
speak but we see a very fast learning
effect through the clock we can say as I
said the X auctions come after ten
rounds of experience with the standard
points unclear whether they really say
something about differences in
familiarity what we can say though if
you're worried that people are more
familiar with the dynamic formats and
sort of that's why they do better that's
a valid concern because you learn very
fast from the clock if you think
feedback framing of course that matters
I think it's just an sort of an a
reminder how much it may matter and that
we should in practice pay a lot of
attention to that okay dropout
information
theoretically irrelevant yet you see it
has strong behavioral effects is it a
puzzle well let's look at that in more
detail in
in terms of what mistakes it prevents so
here's let's look first at so the point
of our structural analysis will be to
kind of capture more than just
deviations from dominance but also look
at to the whole distribution of bids
okay so here's the distributor a lot of
information here let me guide you
through so here we look at to make
everything comparable we look at bids -
values okay so here in each of these
pictures on the x-axis we'll have in the
middle we have a zero that means bid
equal value to the left a negative
number means of you under bidding -
right it's over bidding each column
corresponds to a auction format
treatment we also include sheng gu's
data here you can compare these two
these are the same sort of auction
format here for sheng gu here for us I'm
here ascending clock our data and clock
his data if we see these histograms of
relative bits with my values first row
the first three rounds of standard
auction auctions second one the last
four rounds of the standard auctions and
same here for the X auctions early
behavior late behavior for standard
auctions early behavior made behavior
for the exceptions now what's worthwhile
finding out well first of all the
replication was successful at an
enormous detail if you compare these
distributions they look very similar
second initially the major mistake
people make is the under pit there's not
kind of the intuition that we have about
the see of it second price auction but
even here there's a lot of under bidding
now what happens then in all the formats
including our static ones weathers where
they see a clock the mistake of under
bidding gets reduced but the mistake
that remains tends to be an under under
bidding mistake okay so if you look here
the deviations are below the true value
so this is under bidding mistakes only
no it's not true for for the initially
it's true for every treatment or
sanction with data with experience what
kind of mistake do people make Oh in all
formats where there's a clock they get
better okay but the mistake that remains
it tends to be an under bidding mistake
only in the 2p there they start over
bidding and they don't learn not to do
it okay so if we look here here the
mistakes are concentrated above the true
value yeah but wherever they've seen
those off the clock tends to be an under
bidding mistake with one big difference
namely that in the AC where they see how
many other people are still in when
they're bidding
they don't underpaid so much so there
they go closer to their value so
intuitively if you're not sure what
you're actually doing you get worried oh
I might make a mistake I should maybe I
should move out if you see that there's
some other people still bidding you're a
bit more you staying longer okay you're
not so worried about about a perceived
mistake here okay so what we do then is
with we we look at sort of the actual
incentives that people are facing in
these formats and so I actually expected
payoffs
we normalized speeds to relative bits
and we estimate a model of stochastic
bidding behavior as it as a function of
so the actual incentives so if with
logistic errors where the idea is okay
so you make mistakes that are more
costly less often less frequently and we
add some parameters to try to
operationalize some idea of obvious
noise of dominance as follows so let's
think about certain natural model for
the static format for the 2p option so
there let's say PI of a sort of the
expected payoff of bidding a where a
sort of in relative terms to your value
then the probability of making a certain
bit and sort of suppose is modeled like
this was a you if the pay of is higher
you're more likely to to make that bid
and in relative terms there's this
coefficient lambda it's the usuals of
precision coefficient it's very high or
you're very precise you're not noisy at
all and so that's how responsive you are
to actually expected payoffs and we add
these constant terms here for as a sort
of as a weight you put on your dominant
strategy of staying also fitting your
value relative to a deviation beyond
what expected payoffs warrant so it's
kind of an additional weight beyond the
expected payoffs you put on your
dominant strategy and we'll estimate
these some how obvious is it that under
bidding is a mistake how obvious is it
that overfitting is a mistake all right
so this is if you just select based on
expected payoffs plus these extra
weights we also consider sort of a
dynamic perspective on bidding where the
idea is you go through possible bids
starting from low bids and you always
think about well should I bid up to my
true value or should I make this very
bit and so against the actual incentives
correspond to the forgone expected
profit payoff when you drop when you
sort of beat too low
Plus of this extra weight here and sort
of you make this a sequence of binary
decisions should I continue bidding or
should I just beat this amount that's
the natural model I think for the
dynamic auction but you can also think
that even in the static format we also
allow people to go through that just in
their heads so people could also just
think okay I started low bid and now
decide well do I increase it or do I
make this bit okay and so if the
probability of making a certain bit just
corresponds to the probability of
raising it you know bidding are raising
it are minus one time staying in okay so
we allow we fit both models to every
format and see what the data tell us
which is the model that fits behavior
this and we estimate these parameters
we don't observe the winning bids yes
there we have to Eve to compute this we
have to impute winning bids and we do so
we say it's either it's either the the
winner's winners true value if that's
less than actual the second highest bid
so to speak we take that plus one
increment okay
so what can we answer with this model so
we can address the question whether
actually people do they respond to
expect actual expected payoffs do they
is is the static perspective on how you
choose your bid more does that fit the
behavior better or is it more this
dynamic thought process that fits better
or the second point and the the other
question is do does the sort of dominant
strategy receive an extra weight beyond
what expected payoffs tell you and we
allow the different different parameter
for under bidding versus over bidding
okay and finally of course how do these
effects depend on the auction format
what we find is initially monitoring
actual monetary incentives don't explain
behavior at all the precision parameter
is not significantly different from zero
then it becomes significant and in terms
of how people choose their bids actually
in the in the Silpat format oops
plane to P there the static model where
I just consider all your bids and may
choose your bid based on expected
payoffs plus these extra weights that
fits best
whereas in n in all of the other formats
even those sort of wave bid statically
but then you see a clock the dynamics of
perspective on how you choose your bid
fits best meanings of once you've seen
the clock you start thinking like okay
you think about your bids starting with
low bids and you think about should I
increase it or should I stop here and
that that's a natural model
dynamic auction actually also fits
behavior best for those where you don't
actually pay dynamically but you see the
clock now what about these extra weights
on the dominant strategy
well dominance so is it's it's obvious
but more so and actually only so for
under bidding and it's a most obvious in
the standard AC there otherwise there's
no difference okay so what we conclude
from this is that behavior is quite well
organized you except for the very noisy
first two two rounds or so it's well
organized buys up the actual material
incentives they face the precision
parameter that we get is the same we
estimated to be the same across all
formats so no one significant
differences across formats so a dollar
is worth the dollar a euro is worth a
euro to everybody in every format and so
we operationalized obvious nasir for
this context the extra pulled towards
the dominant strategy beyond the
monetary incentives and we would think
that this tells us that seeing the clock
resolves the bidding changes the way you
think about how you choose yours the way
you think about your incentives and how
you choose your your strategy so it
changes this way of thinking to the
dynamic kind of should I increase
incremental way of thinking also in the
formal a static options now if you think
about stochastic choice model if you if
it's always this should increase or
should I stop you should increase should
I stop here this off mechanically
produces a tendency towards under
bidding because as you approach your
value it's basically a coin basically go
to a coin flip because pay off
differences get vanish now what
counteracts that is that bidders quickly
realized that under bidding is dominated
okay but never they never really realize
that over bidding is dominated so that
means when you statically look at your
auction at your bids and choose from the
static perspective
because you don't see that over bidding
is dominated so you make these
overfitting mistakes whereas for the
interpreting mistakes under the dynamic
perspective that's mitigated because you
see oh under bidding is dominated so
that counteracts that and only in the
standard AC auctions there the this
under bidding the slight under bidding
mistake that remains also goes away so
to speak and the interpretation would be
that if you see others are still in you
also have a tendency to staying longer
okay so conclusion yes I don't need to
summarize I think maybe bit provocative
but dominance seems theoretically very
appealing but it's practically not so
special in the sense that people don't
approach a mechanism thinking in terms
of dominance they don't look for
dominant strategy so they won't find
them they don't think in those terms so
they need to learn it yeah learning
should be simple when it's when there's
no sort of it's not it's not about
strategic issues it's just a dominant
strategy but they're still feedback also
how you frame the feedback is crucial
for the speed of learning if you do it
the right way people very quickly figure
out the dominant strategy if you don't
they don't know now I'm theoretical
obvious here the dynamic bidding seems
to help learning that's also not so it's
not necessary you can just show them the
clock and they figure it out as I said
regarding initial play versus learning
initial play it's not clear potential
differences in familiarity may have
large effects but we don't know whether
they exist as a general point obvious
strategy proven is is not generally
feasible and may also sometimes be not
practical to run dynamic mechanisms so
these kind of things are separate
aspects of design choice to also have
independent interest at the same time
framing is quite unavoidable seams are
quite powerful tool when we sort of
would take away from this as a
suggestion
is sort of small-scale dry runs before
large-scale implementations of
mechanisms where people can play around
with them and one sort of would be
interested in seeing what kind of
feedback helps people figure out how
their choice effect sort of the outcome
in the mechanism and that would also be
a suggestion that applies to the medical
residency match it seems advice doesn't
work so well
explanation also doesn't maybe if you
have them play a mini version of the
algorithm where they see how their own
report affects what what they get would
help them see that it makes sense to
submit their preferences truthfully okay
that's it thank you
[Applause]
that's correct
so the assumption that's always so we
followed after standard with us with
this qualification we just assume people
don't view this as a repeated game but
so narrowly consider each game in
isolation yeah it's the same is true
with obvious dominance also not clear
that's obviously dominant in that
repeated
okay why don't we thank Sebastian
[Applause]